Kellyanne Conway imploded on CNN with
Anderson Cooper of regarding this Russia
blackmail file this is just amazing
Anderson Cooper very clearly wanted to
talk to Kelly Anne Conway about the fact
that CNN was right in their reporting
that Trump was briefed about the alleged
existence of this Russian blackmail file
Kellyanne Conway did not want to admit
that and she went the route of fake news
let's take a look at clip number one
buckle up folks get get the popcorn Joey
at today's press conference Sean Spicer
conflated unsubstantiated claims at
BuzzFeed release with what CNN reported
and I was surprised by that because he
said BuzzFeed and CNN made the decision
to run with the unsubstantiated claim
right that's simply not true and what
CNN said is that CNN is not reporting on
details of that memo as it has not
independently corroborated the specific
allegation do you acknowledge here and
now that CNN did not release the 35 page
unsubstantiated claims against Donald
Trump and it was misleading and untrue
for Sean Spicer to suggest otherwise
no our incoming press secretary Sean
Spicer was exactly right as Alma
Anderson CNN went first yesterday and
BuzzFeed went second we didn't reveal
anybody reported right I didn't say that
you did but you linked or moisture in
there we Tory
let me just tell you Anderson let's back
up I know CNN must be feeling the heat
today of having a headline yesterday at
around 6:30 p.m. that said quote Intel
chief presented Trump with information
that Russia could compromise Russia had
information to compromise him that is
just false and he saw through NBC news
reports today tweets from people at
Politico no friend of Donald Trump and a
lot of frankly a lot of outlets print
and electronic outlets so we lucked into
hesitant to go forward with anything
close to a CNN or BuzzFeed did well
Megan you're complaining but they went
first I was complaining nothing I didn't
know what CNN did
Anderson you know you're a responsible
journalist you've gone all over the
world you're widely what I did
inaccurate about what CNN reported oh my
goodness the whole headline you you go
with the entire story for by lines and a
story that's just not true that the
president like was presented with this
information
and that it was appended in a two-page
document this is exactly true
president-elect Trump said yes I was
told about this Anderson Cooper is
exactly right Kellyanne Conway she's
committed she had one bite of the cookie
she might as well have the entire thing
she keeps it going take a look to the
briefing NBC has said it was not other
people have said it embassies are now
receiving NBC has said was not verbally
presented and CNN never said it was
verbally presented in fact we said CNN
in their reporting based on multiple
sources said we don't know if it was
verbally presented what CNN said was and
I quote classified documents presented
last week to President Obama and
president like Trump included
allegations that Russian operatives
claimed to have compromising personal
and financial information about mr.
Trump multiple US Energy and Rec
knowledge of the briefings tell CNN
Anderson your sources are not correct
and the fact is that in he'll join me
you're saying in that intelligence
briefing there was no information in any
of the documents that of that two-page
summary so two things on that number one
we don't discuss the classified
information that is presented in
intelligence we decide whether it was or
excuse me so let's see if I understand
we're four minutes into an interview
where Kellyanne Conway is denying
specifics in terms of a classified
intelligence briefing and four minutes
in where it starts to look like she
clearly can't sustain this lie and farce
anymore she was oh we don't talk about
what was or wasn't in a classified
briefing
wait you don't discuss it or it didn't
happen how can it be both let's continue
Anderson if you just if you want me to
talk I know CNN is feeling the heat
today I think you guys are going to come
on and discuss it we filled it what'd he
do we feel that you've got this raw
information this complete ridiculous
fake news actually just fake is not
honorable sources the kind of news
agencies New York Times well you just
I'm surprised you going argue with me it
has it has not been backed up by
credible news sources and you know as
well as I do that these rumors were
running around from
every news outlet was chasing these
rumors we're not allowed not to Anderson
because CNN went first and had this
breathless report every sit was a
bombshell
earth-shattering report last night so
listen this went on for ten minutes I
don't even have time to play you more of
it we are going to play a little more
but we're out of time the bottom line is
it is correct to have reported CNN is
correct when they reported that this was
something Trump was briefed on Trump
admitted that James clapper has
confirmed that Kellyanne Conway is
absolutely wrong she's embarrassing
herself she pivots redirects lies
attacks the source and then says we
don't talk about classified briefings
well you've spent ten minutes talking to
Anderson Cooper about it and in the
middle said you don't discuss classified
briefings and absolute and utter
embarrassment I'm out of time no
voicemail today we will talk to you on
the bonus show who is the most hated
company in America it might surprise you
it might not those stories and more on
the bonus show thanks for watching this
video before you watch the next one
remember we're raising money to expand
the David Pakman show big league as well
as expand progressive activism go to
david pakman.com slash donate donations
of any size are much appreciated